this is the darwaza gas crater in
turkmenistan a man-made abyss that the
soviets in their quest for oil
accidentally opened in the karakum
desert as a result of a gas leak a
crater that since 1971 has been engulfed
in flames without ever extinguishing for
a single day so turkmenistan
turkmenistan is a mix of contrasts of
beauty and mess this is what you can
find online when you search for
turkmenistan turkmenistan is one of the
most remote and accessible land in the
world it's a forgotten nation not to
mention its history what's its capital
don't look on wikipedia i give you three
seconds to answer
azkabad you got it awesome you're going
to go like as a reward what many of you
might not know is that turkmenistan was
and is still today one of the most
unusual dictatorship ever but let me
explain how they got there it's history
time turkmenistan isolation needs to be
seen in its geopolitical context the
country is bordered to the south by iran
and afghanistan to the north by
kazakhstan to the northeast by
uzbekistan and to the west by the
caspian sea the karakum desert dominates
almost all of the country about 90
percent of the territory while in the
south a series of mountain ranges form a
natural border with iran and afghanistan
in the north the border with uzbekistan
is partly divided by the amudaria river
one of the most important water
resources in central asia turkmenistan's
river valleys have sustained its
civilization since ancient times
although the region was dominated for
many centuries by turkmen tribes
turkmenistan as a political entity only
emerged in the last century during the
soviet period the country was an
underdeveloped socialist republic for
the soviets turkmenistan served as a
supplier of raw materials starting from
raw cotton fiber oil and natural gas its
main resources for the rest the country
was supported by the meager economic aid
from the ussr in boosting cotton
production there was an intense
development of the irrigation system
which however produced very serious
damage to the surrounding environment
the flow of the amudaria was redirected
to the main desert farms these only
contributed to the drying up of the aral
lake on the border between kazakhstan
and uzbekistan an environmental disaster
that among other things fueled
disagreements among central asian
nations over the consumption of natural
resources and waterways with the end of
subsidies the fall of soviet union and
the country's independence in 1991
pretty much everything non-related with
the gas industry went bankrupt
unemployment arose among the highest in
the world more than 60 percent and this
led the country to export gas at
competitive prices in order to face the
hegemony of russia in the area once
independent turkmenistan began
celebrating a policy of neutrality this
monument in ashgabat was the symbol of
such neutrality and served the
government as a way to create favorable
diplomacy with its central asian
neighbors hopefully this tower was also
created to attract the attention of
foreign investors turkmenistan after all
needed money that's basically what
everyone needs come on it needed money
to revitalize the gas industry and
establish an emirates state just like
kuwait did before with approximately 2.7
trillion cubic meters of natural gas
reserves turkmenistan was in fact the
second largest producer in the formed
soviet union and is currently the ninth
largest producer globally a share that
could let turkmenistan achieve
incredible economic development
in an ideal world however after
independence the government of
turkmenistan was never eager to
implement serious reforms for example by
liberalizing prices and allowing a real
private sector to emerge despite some
improvements in recent years a large
part of the population still lives below
the poverty line and the economy is
fragile and stagnant contrary to the
claims of the country's former president
for life the so-called turkmen bashi a
title which means literally father of
all turkmens according to
turkmenbashian's annual reports the
national growth rate was 20
in august 2006.
i smell something rotten in here based
on the official versions the president
died of a heart attack a few months
later according to others he was
poisoned what's certain is that he had
no way of appreciating the benefits that
this alleged 20 percent growth rate
would have had on the country but the
real question is who's supermeriat nyaz
and why is it so important for all of us
well maybe not all of us was he a
megalomaniac dictator a liar a madman in
power a shrewd calculator who leveraged
national symbolism but he is not a porn
star
to answer these questions all it takes
is a simple
yes
let's see why every single year on
september 12th the citizen of
turkmenistan gathered to celebrate
runamade the national holiday honoring
the runama literally the book of the
soul a work of spiritual teachings
addressed to the nation and written by
the president himself or by one of his
fellow's ghost writers but never say
never nihazov was a poet after all and a
dictator in 2002 in the capital ashgabat
a massive statue of the book was raised
and every evening at eight o'clock the
cover was raised and opened to the
public the main square an audio
recording of sam passages together with
a video projected on the page of the
book was broadcasted building huge
stages was one of turkmen bash's main
obsessions even better if these huge
statues were covered in gold and were
dedicated to him and recently also to
his dog
yep this fixation was so strong that
turkmenbashi imposed that they were
spread in all the cities of the nation
referring to this obsession niyazov
repeatedly stressed that it wasn't due
to reasons of megalomania but simply
because it was the turkmen people who
wanted them all over the country reverse
psychology at its finest another
interesting case of nyazov mentality was
the new year's eve of 1999 when every
citizen of ashgabat was given a watch
with a picture of the president himself
our berlusconi did the same in italy in
1999 when he gave us a calculator to
calculate the euro lira exchange rate i
see no difference at all mias of strange
policies served as a way to emphasize
the turkmen national symbolism to the
point that many foreign commentators
described turkmenistan under nyazov as a
fascist state inserted in a post-soviet
space nyazov transferred soviet ideology
to secure the narrative of a turkmen
national superiority in his runarma
miazov argued that turkmen national
development began more than 5 000 years
ago and as he said turkmenistan can now
live separate and isolated from other
states while maintaining its traditions
and customs this was the turning point
for turkmenistan when it began to look
more like north korea than russia in
every place the words and the most
striking quotations of the glorious
leader as it was called were inscribed
on walls plates and billboards a series
of great public monuments exalted its
virtues cities dams roads libraries and
schools all named and built in izana
knowledge of the main chapters of runama
was demanded not only from government
officials but also from ordinary people
for instance people were required to
repeat some of the runama quotes when
taking the driving license test to
ensure that turkmen would not lose sight
of their glorious leader in their daily
activities turkmenbashi invented another
way to remind citizens of his presence
he declared that every month of the year
should be renamed january was named
turkmenbashi in his honor while april
was named in memory of his mother gurban
sultan yeah i know it sounds weird but
in turkmenistan worshipping family
members was and still is in fact one of
the hallmarks of the regime much more
than in other neighboring countries
before becoming known as turkmenbashi
and as the spiritual father of the
country nyazo was one of the many
faceless grey and anonymous local party
bureaucrats a staunch supporter of the
soviet ideology in turkmenistan yet as
the union unraveled nyazov switched
political flags shifting surprisingly
quickly in favor of turkmen nationalism
a case in point was when at the end of
the last formal meeting of the party
after lunch nyazov gathered the same
members in the same hall to fund the
democratic party of turkmenistan we are
the communist party
oh never mind we are not the communist
party anymore by consolidating control
over all aspects of society economy and
government turkmenbashi exploited what
remained of the skeleton of the soviet
system to create a political machine
based on constraint fear nepotism and
patronage in taking advantage of the
weakness of what was considered a de
facto country made up of tribal chief
and herding clans turkmenbashi installed
a hybrid system where quote unquote
traditional elements of tribal society
were combined with modern elements of
the typical soviet power hierarchy but
how was it that nyazov a single man was
able to take control of turkmenistan by
himself well one single word can be
enough monopolization monopolization of
the country's vast reserves of natural
gas from which turkmenistan didn't
benefit at all during the soviet period
by extracting and shipping gas through
the pipelines to russia the country
earned meager revenues from the sale of
its primary commodity and years of
exploited denationalization of gas and
took control of all the industrial
plants but sadly for the population the
brokerage companies that operated on his
behalf would have done nothing but
commercialized turkmen gas and channeled
the revenues into the president's bank
accounts revenues that served as his
main source of income to give a
semblance of general economic
improvements turkmenbashi undertook a
series of day-ring state projects this
was done to consolidate its consensus
among a population that at that time do
remember registered a high literacy the
capital ashgabat from an underdeveloped
village became a showcase for foreign
investors made of majestic public
buildings in white marble sumptuous
parks and white streets which are still
today almost empty water scarcity was a
daily issue and yet more than a thousand
fountains were built behind the
glittering facade of public buildings
turkmenistan remained a country marked
by isolation poverty and the systematic
suppression of freedom of speech the
only applicable law was that of nyazov
himself who besides controlling the
information and media deprived courts
and parliamentary institution of their
power years of justified the absence of
pro-democratic reforms due to what he
called the turkmen mentality there is a
mentality that was at odds with
pro-western democracy miazov banned
everything that was not part of the
turkmen culture these included video
games car radios
belay and opera long hair and beards for
men and last but not least dogs because
according to him when walking down the
streets of the capital dogs gave off a
bad smell tuchmanistan became a sort of
big brother managed by a single man the
term bread was changed to his mother's
name doctors instead of swearing to
hippocrates as were to him the cyrillic
alphabet was replaced with the turkmen
alphabet similar to the latin one and
any exam could be passed only after
passing a morality test as well oh yeah
and among other extravagances nyezov
suggested to the old people to chew
chicken bones a bit like dogs too saying
that in this way they would avoid all
dental problems who needs implants
anyway contributing to the isolation was
the systematic dismantling of school
libraries and cultural clubs after all
it's much easier to keep control over an
ignorant and uneducated population isn't
it the mass media and even the police
force were corrupted with bribes as
stated by a journalist who fled the
country for the past 12 years
turkmenbashi plunged the country into a
neo-stalinist nightmare although the
country had adopted shortly after
independence a constitution conforming
to international standards it didn't
actually have the basic structure to
defend any single civil liberties
basically the constitution became just
scrap paper that turkmenbashi punctually
reshaped his own will another nice
aspect of nyasa were his big lies by
exaggerating the country's progress and
insisting that turkmen citizens were
lucky to live in a country with advanced
freedoms and privileges nyazo exalted
and justified not only his own position
as the country father's defender but
also his attacks on anyone who
questioned the country's progress
attacks that were condemned as
accusations made by supporters of
foreign powers whether it be american
russian or european he has repeatedly
said that turkmenistan was free of
crimes of any kind and that no rights
had ever been violated in the country in
november 2002 however following an
assassination attempt against him the
president seized the opportunity to cast
suspicion on some ministers who were
openly against him including the
ex-foreign minister boris sheikh muradov
nyoza also accused the utzbeck minority
in the country and the uzbek government
of being involved in the matter a way to
highlight once again at the expense of
the uzbek minority how special turkmens
were support to nyazov came from those
who ran the country's key sectors namely
the energy banking and agricultural
sectors corruption and political
compromise did the rest it was either
unconditional loyalty to the great
leader or elimination as nyazov often
declared in his public rallies there was
no opposition in turkmenistan i think we
should trust him and not see this as a
subtle threat the country's predominant
religion itself islam had to pass
through the filter of propaganda in one
of the sessions of the people's council
miazov proclaimed himself as the new
prophet muhammad he went even beyond
when he claimed that his book
was the equivalent of the quran
according to niyazov whoever read the
runama aloud three times a day would go
straight to heaven as you can well
understand islam underwent a strong
ideological control in order to limit
its potential impacts on the population
islam could have been an alternative
choice and potentially a political mean
to foster opposition after all what's
the point of reading quran when you
already had runama by the time nyazov
passed away the country was in a pitiful
state with the economy completely
paralyzed lacking internal and external
investments with the gas and oil route
at stake between russia and china with
no monetary aid either from the big
international funds or from domestic
bank insurances with the new president
gurban guli berdi muhammed there has
been a very small change of direction
[Applause]
oh yeah i see there are still big
inequalities think of the average
salaries an average turkmen don't get
more than 20 dollars per month and
that's the sad reality of turkmenistan
we'll probably have to wait a long time
before one of the most famous quotes
from ronama can come true for real our
country is not only for the turkmen
people but for all those people who want
to lead turkmenistan into a golden
century
[Music]